good afternoon I hope you all have not
fallen asleep from lunch and I don't put
you farther to sleep
um so you think by starting I'd like to
start by thanking the organizers for
inviting me out to give this talk
um just a brief introduction of who I am
and why I'm talking to you I I'm trained
as a physicist
um in my graduate work I study two
systems one of which is a colloidal
system which is a analog for uh oh no oh
no
um okay be closer to the mic great
um now I can't see my notes
okay we're still good all right
um so it's a colloidal system which is a
uh dense amorphous Jam system which is
an analog for some glassy systems and
then I studied the vapor layer
underneath the light and frost drop I'll
explain both of these a little more oh
come on
um this is an introduction I'm currently
at nsls2 where I do data acquisition I'm
the current project leader of matplotlib
and I was recently named a psf fellow
um something I started doing is putting
acknowledgments at the beginning of
putting acknowledges at the beginning of
talks just to make sure they don't get
rushed at the end so to start by
thanking uh Mike drop boom Eric fearing
and the whole map all the tape and
Mike's actually right there in the
second row
um when I was a grad student started
working in open source they really are
who taught me how to like do software uh
in a way that is usable by other people
um I'd also like to thank Dan Allen
kenlauer my colleagues at b l they're
really the core we built out blue sky
with and we learned quite a bit about
how to build these systems from scratch
together
and father to thank my wife Dora
um she's also a developer and uh you
know
contribute quite a bit to these slides
as we talked you know she saw early
versions of this talk going on as I was
developing it and of course I'll just
see the support of through grad school
and supporting my open source habit
um so I think this is probably an easy
pitch for this room that like software
is critical to the future of science I
know as I heard as we heard in the
keynote this morning
um this link is to you know the site
here is to a talk from Dan Katz but
she's giving you their today or
yesterday at a meeting in Europe uh
funders of research software uh that has
sets like 90 of academic researchers
report softwares is uh they use software
and 60 say it's critical and I suspect
that the 40 who say it's not critical
are buying either to themselves or the
survey
um and the reason it's pretty software
lets you ask different questions right
there's things that you just can't do by
hand because it's too big it's too it's
too complex you can't you you know we've
moved on from analog film
um
and finally in a really something's very
interesting is that software lets you
encapsulate techniques and Analysis
you've you've developed in a way that is
natively shareable and reusable by other
people
um so
uh
the size of like modern science data is
you know is one of the things driving
you know drives us to our software and
the term Big Data gets to learn a lot
gets thrown around a lot you may ask
like what does that actually mean and I
think trying to go for like a like a
size in bytes is not the right metric
it's really
bigger than your field is used to right
fields that have always been heavily
based on Imaging you know getting into
the gigabytes and terabytes a decade ago
was normal I'm like that's you know
they're rolled past that now but that
was you know normal then but there's
some Fields now that are getting to like
the megabyte scale and they're starting
to run into these same problems so it's
really when the data gets bigger then
you can deal with using your current
techniques is when you feel you've moved
to pick data
um an interesting connection to my my
graduate work is um the first
measurements of colloids were done by uh
John baptiste's parent
um you know in 1908 uh they actually did
this with a very cool physical Optical
setup where uh called a camera lucidia
where in one eye you can see your
microscope and the other eye you can see
like a drawing surface you can mark on
and they would just Track by hand where
the colloids were over time and using
this technique they measured you know
thousands of displacement vectors
um and your parent got the low prize in
1926 uh for this work because you know
it proved that molecules existed and you
know to settled if the world is
continuous or made up of subatomic of
small particles I also track particle
underground Browning Motion in my
graduate work uh did not get the Nobel
Prize however the first our keynote
speaker tomorrow did
um
and what I could do with suffer is that
I could look at much much larger fields
of view you know Karen was tracking one
particle at a time I was tracking 20 000
per frame at I think 10 Hertz you know
over thousands of frames over hundreds
of experiments and by having the size I
can make measurements about the
structure and dynamics of what these
particles were doing that you couldn't
access just by looking at smaller
volumes
um the second project I worked on which
again the software was critical to the
work that I did is
um so this is this is the view of the
bottom of a liner Frost drop uh if
you're not
determined not be familiar but you've
all seen this effect if you take a drop
of water and throw it in a really hot
frying pan sometimes it like hits the
surface and like oils immediately and
sometimes it like pops up in a little
ball and skitters around and that that's
the light and frost effect and what's
going on is as the drops getting closer
close enough it starts evaporating you
get a vapor layer between the drop and
the surface and it acts like a uh a
puffer coat and keeps the drop from
insulates the drop from the hot surface
and it can live far longer than it could
and it's now frictionless like on its
own little air cable
um the lab I was in had developed a
technique to use interference Imaging to
look uh at you look at the gap between a
fluid layer and a surface and a postdoc
lab Justin Burton uh upload you know did
this with a line of fresh drop and Guy
images look very much like this one and
what you're seeing here is as you go
around the ring you can see my mouse is
that every time you go from a white
finish to a dark Fringe around you're
either going up or down by a quarter
wavelength of light and so using this
technique you can very carefully measure
uh the variation of the thickness of
this
um of the gap
um Justin look at this cat you know went
into image J and clicked off these
points by hand and met you know measured
the profile of the rim by hand uh and
like this was a new and interesting
result because it's always been assumed
to be like uniform around the rim and
publish a paper and like this was great
I saw this in group and he said I bet
you could automate that and get a Time
series
um Justin didn't agree we had some
discussions and I know I uh I saw
settled that by just doing it
um and this should also tell you
Justin's now a professor at Emery and I
I do what I do so this should includes
of where our careers were going
um
so you know I took a couple weeks to get
the first version working about you know
six to seven months later uh there's
some reasonable code that I pulled out
and put on GitHub as its own Standalone
project and about 18 months after that I
wrote up my my paper on this and
graduated
um
so before next slide I spent you
imagine the slice around this ring and
the up and down patterns of the of the
fringes as we go through
so what we see here is that each
vertical line in this is one of those
slices around an image and as we go
horizontally we go through time so what
we're watching is the evolution of this
Rim as it varies the anything that's
basically a constant color of Darker
light is at the same height between all
those frames and then it's colored by
the overall height of these things so by
you know charting through about a
terabyte of raw like high speed imagery
I had access to a 3000 frame per second
camera uh I could extract out these very
interesting room Dynamics over a very
long period of time uh and this really
could not have been done by hand right
you can't do you can't click on a 100
something fringes at 100 000 frames and
expect to graduate you know in your
lifetime
um your professors might disagree but
you can't uh
so
uh I mentioned I pulled that that code
out you know I called the track by this
you know a bit of reusable code that was
for linking features between frames
um and just over a decade ago which is a
terrifying thing to say I got this email
from a colleague who said you know I you
know there's a common technique in our
field I'd implemented one half of it he
didn't but the other maybe we should be
friends
um in the end we end up merging our code
bases uh he was gracious enough to keep
thought the project keep the name I'd
given it
um and at this point about 30 people
have contributed to this project and
even though Dan and I both mostly moved
on from this type of research this
project has become self-sustaining
um and about a year and a half well
a couple years after you know Dan
graduated a year after I did and then
joined me at Brookhaven and has been you
know been uh
there with me ever since and it's
nothing but my closest and most
beautiful collaborator for the last
seven or eight years
um
I think this brings up both science and
software have this this myth that a lone
genius is the is the you know is the
archetype that's going to work right
like one person alone can solve it and I
think this is really harmful
um to some degree science as a whole is
a collaborative effort to collectively
understand the world right we don't
publish solely to gamer age indexes we
publish to share information with other
people so they can then build on it and
you know build their Collective
understanding of the world
uh it's really like any useful software
these days is bigger than one person can
like even physically write you know by
themselves in their lifetime right if
you think about the amount of
engineering effort that goes from I'm
running a Jupiter notebook displaying
machine learning models all the way down
through like the Fortran and GPU code
that it takes to run that like that's a
stupendous amount of engineering effort
that no one person could do
um
and just with my observation that any
piece of software I've written in
collaboration with someone else has been
a better piece of software than any
software I've only by myself I think
just the having more than one point of
view having more than one person
thinking about it is just invaluable
making sure you've got good results
and uh this is at least the second time
this this this picture is shown up at
this conference
um this is from I think it's from from
Jake van implaus's 2015 sci-fi keynote
uh showing kind of the Rings of the
signified Furniture system and
everything I've talked about so far was
built entirely on this deck
and interestingly the trackpad that
piece of software that's a byproduct of
Dan andized research has demonstrated
almost 300 times in a variety of domains
well outside of the the field Dan and I
worked in which is a subsection of soft
transmitter physics you know including
uh climate one of the papers is track
you know it's using trackpad to track uh
ships in the Atlantic to Flying
correlations with clouds and then
climate change you know biomedical
things like high impact journals like
this has been the impact of that
software has been far greater than the
impact of the actual academic research
that motivated it at least in my case
um
another
measure measure way we can measure the
impact of the Scientific Python
Community overall is looking at what
fraction of papers on the archive uh we
think include a matplotlit figure
um it's been true for a while back to
like a seven or something for a PDF and
like the early odds for the vector the
raster back ends that as part of writing
out a file for matplotlib uh and there's
a standard metadata like producer that
tells you what piece of software wrote
this file I think the intent is so that
if you've got a broken SVG you know who
to go file the bug report with uh but
because
this Watermark is there and Will Survive
the process of making a PDF if you just
grant you know just grab every PDF on
the archive and search for the byte
string matte plotlet you can determine
if that paper has matte color figure in
it or not
um and about a month ago Matt Rocklin
who is here someplace uh we're chatting
at a at a meeting and he wrote some Dash
code that in about five minutes will
chew through the terabyte of archive
data and to answer this question and so
you can see here's that over time we're
now at something like 17 of papers on
the archive uh including matplotlib and
this is definitely A4 because there's
some post processing steps they'll strip
it out and this is all papers not just
papers that include a figure it's like
yeah as a community we're having a huge
impact on science at least the parts of
science that are publishing archive
um
so
a
you might want to ask like how can you
think about doing software in a way that
means that means that may make sure your
software will have an impact and not
just be your little you know collection
of scripts that do that solve your
problem in no one else's
um and this is an analogy actually
um that I I'm stealing from Peter Wang
of Anaconda
uh whereas if we think about what's
above the water line here that's kind of
the application that's the code that's
solving the problem you actually want to
solve because again like we don't write
software just for like fun I mean it is
fun but that's not why we do it right
you always write software to do
something else right there's some
there's some goal you want to get done
this the software is a tool to do and so
what's above the water line is the tool
that's doing whatever it is you want
um and if you compare the top and bottom
of this diagram
yeah what's about the one always about
the same like yeah okay I could have
made the volcanoes flat but details
um however if you wanted to then expand
uh you know and do something out here
like kind of between the first and
second if it's you know in the volcano
model you're you know you have to do
some work you have to get below the
water line dig in but you don't have to
go all the way to the sea floor whereas
in the Matchstick model if you've built
a very specific you know vertically
integrated application when you you have
to dig all the way to the bottom or
build all the way to the bottom for any
new thing you want to build
and you can think of the history of the
you know of the Scientific Python
ecosystem over the last two really two
decades now as this process of building
those volcanoes up slowly and slowly as
more you know from the foundational
libraries more and more domain specific
libraries are built and it's easier and
easier for people who just want to get
something done to find the tool to solve
their problems
so some
uh
concrete waste a way to think of this
distinction is to think about software
being either library library like or
application like it's not this is not
the the only access you can start
software is not the best it may not be
the best but it's an interesting access
to think about
and then certain application like its
job is to solve a problem for me right
now like I need to get something done
you know I as a human have a goal and
this software is going to help me do it
on the other hand I'll lie if you're
thinking more like a library your goal
is to solve a class of problems for
someone else at some other time that
someone else may be you in the future
but like you're you're thinking a little
more generally
um and that really there's kind of this
distinction where an application really
is used by a human the output of that
application is goes into someone's
eyeballs and like they understand it and
Advance their own objectives whereas in
a library the output is then used by
other code and these you know this helps
Drive some of your design decisions
um in an application you can make many
many assumptions because you say like
you know I'm making an application to
visualize you know the the Penguins on
these two islands and then you can then
based on user input you can say that you
know you're asked about dogs I don't do
that I know you know did you misspell
penguins that wasn't a great analogy uh
whereas in the library case you want to
make many fewer assumptions you still
need to make some but many fewer so that
you your your tool is usable to as many
people as possible because you want to
leave it up to the application
developers to bring their applications
to the problem their assumptions to the
problem
um similarly an application may be very
painted but I O it says I need to files
named in such and such a way with such
metadata in in the fields and in a
library you probably want to be as
agnostic as possible to where you know
how the data got to you you're going to
want to take in you know numpy arrays
pianos data frames you know python data
types things in memory that you know you
don't care where it came from you don't
care where it's going but your job is to
work on that data
um and finally an application you never
want to fail right like you should you
should try to guess what the user wanted
to do you should make you know because
you're making those assumptions you try
to be helpful and in the worst case
scenario you say like a nice error
message like I'm sorry please do please
try again we're in the case of a library
you want to fail as hard and fast as
possible something's not what you expect
because you want to raise that exception
so again so the application developer
can catch that exception and then bring
their assumptions as to how to solve
this
um
a you know a pictorial way of looking at
this is if in a very abstracted sense if
the horizontal axis is all the things
you might want to do with a computer and
the virtual vertical actions is how hard
it is to do that in the case of
application you have this energy
landscape essentially that's very
you know has a very very deep narrow Gap
and if you want to do what the
application does like your life is great
like it just works you're happy and like
you can move on with whatever it is
you're trying to do
and because of a library it's never
going to be as easy as an application to
do any given thing
uh but if you want to move away from the
initial thing that the authors imagined
in the case of application you're gonna
you you know it's very likely to hit
this cliff and like either it's not
possible or you end up finding you end
up building like elaborate constructs to
work around the assumptions the library
make that were different than you wanted
to make
application made that's definitely want
to make whereas a library it's a little
harder but you've got this much gentler
energy landscape that as you go away
it's still possible and you can then
build your own application with your
assumptions bringing that that um Valley
down someplace else
so trying to
make this even more concrete and find a
case study that fit two versions of
which on the same screen at a font size
that was readable in this room was
surprisingly hard
is a bit contrived but bear with me
so let's say you have directories of
Tiff files the there's something about
what sample the that was a picture of is
in the directory name and then
for your analysis you need to know the
temperature that was taken at and that
happens to be uh if you split the file
name by underscores is in the third
section but you have to drop the c
because it carries units I mean units
are good but you can't make them into
integers
um
I yeah
so taking an application point of view
we could write some code that looks like
this you know we use pathlib to get a
glob uh we Loop over those file names we
use to file to open up that gets us the
actual image we then do a bunch of
string munging path munching through
this information out and then we do you
know a trip you know
in this case a trivial computation but
you can imagine this being much more
elaborate about you know whatever you're
trying to do and like this works and if
your goal is like I got this director of
files I need to process them right now
to answer a question this is this is a
good choice of what to do
on the other hand if you're thinking
more as a library you might want to make
a function that takes in that file name
and Returns the parsed data At You Know
sample name and temperature
and then in your analysis we've changed
that for Loop just until this into a
dictionary comprehension
and where what we're iterating over is
the actual values we care about and so
now if if next week when uh you know the
the unnamed grad student who is yourself
decides to add a fourth section on the
front and now suddenly you have to get
the fourth split not the third right in
the application case you have to go
through and rewrite every place that
you've ever used
you copy pasted this code around your
code base and I've never done that I
swear
um
whereas in the library case you know you
can uh you just write a new function and
then you just switch out which function
you use you know as as you need so a
little more a little bit more upfront
investment but hopefully a payoff in the
long term as your code is more flexible
and maintainable
um so
uh
obviously not every not every every
piece of code needs to turn into like a
widely used foundational Library like
like if we only did that we missed a
point because again no one's doing the
actual things this computer you know the
computers exist for
but what are some questions that can
kind of drive you a little bit more
towards that Library mindset as you
develop your code so the first thing I
always try to think was like what
assumptions are you making right every
time you write a piece of code that's
encoding some assumption that you're
making about what problem you're trying
to solve what the parameters of the
problem are and like why you're doing it
so just be careful to think through what
those actually are and sometimes you'll
catch yourself like oh I don't want to
assume this will always be a file name
structure exactly like this maybe I
should take it in an array
um a second thing I really like to think
about is if I make this Choice what
won't I be able to do in the future
because again you know waterfall from
software don't really work right
everything we do is always agile
particularly in a research context where
you know you know the the researcher at
the coal face is they're doing whatever
they need to do to get through the day
and in six months their needs your your
needs their needs whichever
pronounce speaks better to you uh may be
different and so if you think ahead of
like if I make the choice what can't I
do might help drive you to make sure you
don't paint yourself into a corner
um a more positive version of that is
um you know if you look a little bit
ahead and say not what problem am I
trying to sell not just what problem am
I trying to solve today but what problem
am I trying to try to solve next week or
next month and am I designing this in a
way that it's going to be flexible
enough to extend in that direction when
I need to I'm not going to build it now
but I'll lay make sure you know I'll lay
the track or have like a
quasi plan of how I would get there if I
needed it
um and then
I was interested a bit of discipline
I've had good success with this think
carefully what information a given part
of your code needs to know you know kind
of think like uh the security agencies
you know need to know because if you if
a piece of your code knows a piece of
information you're going to eventually
use it there and now you've made now
you've missed that piece of code always
needs to know that information and that
induces lots of coupling between your
covet you know between your code and if
you're able to restrict the smallest
information you can to do its job
you know it might it will push you
towards writing more modular
maintainable
um and finally if you do have users uh
you know you need to think about like
who am I going to break what is the cost
of this change if this is a function in
a you know a module that you that's next
to your script you know the you just you
break the API you fix it you fix the
scripts and you move on which are
something on the scale of not potlib you
know if we break if we put a major
breaking change in like 10 million
people might have changed their code and
so you need to think through like what
the consequences of that change are
going to be
um
so
uh a place where we've applied a number
of these ideas is uh the Blue Sky
project that we've been working on at b
l this is a system for
um you know orchestrating data
acquisition of experimental data
um
I'm not going to talk through this large
diagram
um I think
we've been relatively successful in this
project it's about something between
five and seven years along it's
currently running all the science
operation at nsos 2. there's something
like 1300 researchers come in every year
and you know and about 550 papers come
out of data public published collected
at nsls2 every year
um and this software has also been
adopted by other due light sources so
our peers around the country our peers
internationally uh in addition to
working in the facility scale this has
actually scaled down very well to
University labs and in visual
researchers
I think I think why this this project
has worked out so well is that from the
beginning we very intentionally design
developed this as a collection of
co-designs so like the same people built
built all of these but technically
independent libraries
um and this this is actually paid off in
the sense that one of our University
collaborators uh ripped an entire
subcomponent out and replaced it with
their own and are able to you know make
use of the rest of the ecosystem but not
the part they don't like
um and also we did we developed this in
the open from the start
um you know as soon as we had anything
halfway halfway working it was on GitHub
licensed
um so anyone could see the code anyone
could see you know see our discussions
about where to drive the code and how we
came to decisions and some of our early
collaborators uh helped influence the
direction of the code went to make sure
that it was meeting their needs as well
as ours and in many cases their needs
actually were needs we had that we
hadn't understood yet
um and this worked out very well so if
you happen to own any experimental like
laboratory equipment that you'd like to
automate with python uh we're always
looking for uh new collaborators
um another thing I've been kind of
skirting around in this in this so far
is the concept of like maintaining an
open source project right and like what
what does it mean to be an open source
maintainer and like how are you about
doing that and I think
fundamentally how you define a
maintainer is someone who feels
responsible for the project that could
be an intrinsic motivation just because
they really like the project and want to
help it could be extrinsic because
they're being paid but the end of the
day if you feel responsible for the
project you are a maintainer of that
project
um then what what tools do you need to
be successful at this I think the first
and most critical thing is the
stewardship mindset not an ownership
mindset with the code right once you
once the project is is used and has
users it's no longer your code right
this is code that's used by a bunch of
people to solve presumably solve real
problems they have and you are currently
the steward of that code and you're so
you're you're responsible for taking
care of it but like it's not yours
um
and that also frequently you may join
like historically I've joined a number
of projects that existed well before I
was involved and so like obviously I
don't I it's not mine
um and also like the all the projects
I've worked on like I think they're
useful and I'd like them to continue
once I once I've moved on I don't want
necessarily want to be tied to
you know something I chose to put online
15 years ago forever
um second I think you you needed a lot
of empathy to be a maintainer
um
you know and these big open source
projects everyone's coming from a
different place uh this could be you
know life experience you know background
education domain you know just across
the board you know you talk to everyone
and it you know it takes some effort to
make sure you can find a common ground
uh with those people that have a useful
discussion
and also if your tool is being useful to
someone and they come to you with a bug
report it's because whatever they're
trying to do just got ruined by what by
your code and they're having a pretty
bad day I'm like be kind to them like
they're
yeah they're having a bad day it's not
their fault I mean it might be their
fault but uh
and then third I think you know these
successful projects really are Community
or maintained by a community of people
um and you have to be maintained you
need to be able to work with your new
deaf people skills and you should
definitely go to Melissa's keynote
tomorrow where she'll talk about our our
efforts to improve this in the python
world
and then finally like you do need some
technical skills but frankly this is the
easiest part right this is the most
common you know
almost everyone's room I bet could could
has the technical skills to be a
maintainer on these projects but that's
yeah
um
so you might ask all these things I've
been talking about do I do I still do
science uh no no I don't
um I haven't I haven't been the first
author uh in about eight years like I
don't expect that to change
however I've enabled a lot of science
you know I've been I've supported a lot
of scientists I've ended up on you know
seventh and eighth authors on papers
that having to provide technical
contributions
um I think it's clear that the
the no one has time to both be a domain
expert in the science and a professional
software developer right like I've
chosen to go the developer route and I I
don't do domain research anymore
um
however this doesn't let scientists off
the hook right like I think for a
working scientist these days given the
criticality of software to science
you know you have to be conversant you
have to you know it's a required
professional skill just like you know if
you're a physicist you need no linear
algebra and calculus you know and if you
do any sort of science like you need to
be able to write papers you need to be
able to write grants like that's just
part of the professional function of the
job
um
I think this brings up the idea that you
know the emerging role of a resource
software engineer that's starting to
become uh recognized as an important
role in science
um this is a quote from the United
States research software engineer
Association uh we like an inclusive
definition of research software
Engineers to Encompass those who
regularly use expertise in programming
to advance research this includes
research we spend a significant amount
of time programming full-time software
Engineers who write code to solve
research problems and those somewhere in
between
um
that's a very broad definition like that
could would be a little
more granular I want to talk about like
what a research engineer is not right
this isn't a role for computer science
research this isn't about developing the
latest and greatest new algorithms this
is about applying existing tools and
techniques to solve a research problem
in in whatever your science domain is
uh this also shouldn't be you know 100
fix my code correct um you know if
you're a scientist and you you hire
someone in a role like this you know you
might enjoy bossing a programmer around
and like get some technical support but
you're going to be leaving a lot of
expertise and capability on the table
that when you didn't have to
if you think back to the questions I was
talking about like what you know what
the library mindset is a lot of those
are about understanding what the
software is and why it is and so the for
a good real you know to have an RC be
successful there really needs to be good
communication between the engineer and
the scientist I know you know that you
understand what assumptions are safe to
make which aren't you know where's
where's the signs likely to go next and
like what are the right trade-offs right
like one of my uh one of the scientists
I work with at b l has learned to stop
asking me can I do X because I always
say yes but and then you know explain
why what he wants is actually a 15-year
research project but like it's possible
um
and that it really needs to be a
partnership in collaboration like the
research Engineers need to understand
enough of the domain to have a
conversation with the scientists about
what they're doing and why
but symmetrically the scientists need to
have enough
um software expertise in understanding
to
you know have that have a conversation
with what the limit you know what the
capability is what's possible reasonable
time frames like all that sorts of
things that'll go into designing copies
of software
so
um
advice and conclusion you've given me a
soapbox I'm going to give you some
advice uh use Version Control
uh no really use Version Control
um actually I don't know how I'm doing
on time but if you want to see me have
like flashback panic attacks ask me at
the time I deleted two years of research
code with no backups
[Music]
um
so
uh software is essentially doing science
again I think this is an easy push in
this room
um programming is a required skill for
professional scientists
um if you're going to write any software
I strongly recommend that you have a
library mindset from the start even if
your goal is not to make this into a
widely used package you know
your future user is yourself in six
months and your future self will thank
you for having put in that little bit of
effort now when you're thinking about it
to refactor a new way your structure the
code in a way so you can adapt it
um and then if you if you can as long as
that's working in the open from the
start I think science is better when
it's collaborative and you know the the
Secret Sauce of what you're doing is
that is the data not necessarily the
analysis right we want to be able to
reuse the analysis and you know I think
you're more likely to find collaborators
than someone's going to scoop you uh
also
if if I was aggressive if I put my
research code up and you could do it you
could use it please come talk to me
because I'm having trouble making it
work uh
and finally like make friends build
collaborations and have fun or like
that's the end of the day I think that's
the our high school
so with that I'm Gonna Leave You the
page of links and my contact and I guess
I'm not sure how much how long we have
for questions
okay five minutes for questions
yes
a lot of new people come in who have not
been developers before like fresh bio
Engineers out of college they don't know
how to structure a research project for
code purpose you I have a guide that I
like for that but I do not know if it is
an industry standard you have it you
know because I design your research
software coded by so the the question
was uh are you proving in a lot of new
people uh the asker has a guide of how
they bring in their new people and do I
have a reference uh
I don't have a particular reference I go
to I tend to
granted people
um I mean I learned by working on a big
open source project which is effective
but not yeah is an effective method of
doing that because you will quickly
learn
many of these things just by working in
the code base
and I think some of these also it's very
hard to articulate some of these ideas
you really have to
get in a big project and like see how it
feels to get a sense of why some of
these things matter and how to make the
Judgment calls that are needed
again
just I think the application so I think
the question was how to convince
Business Leaders to vote libraries and
applications
I
I don't have a good answer for that
because I work in a weird quasi-academic
Institution
sorry
it's published but uses data and
software 60 you can't get the data even
when you ask for it of those only a
quarter reproduced using the methods in
the paper uh you kind of talked a lot
about the importance of working in the
open and sharing your software it
doesn't seem like there's a coherent
story or that with the data itself is
this something you you've encountered in
your work and how do you address that
so the question was as mentioned in the
keynote that only 60 you know the not
all data is available and other data is
available most of it doesn't reproduce
and if I've
this does not have a coherent story
about the data this is mostly about
software
um
I think well uh
to some degree yes the
uh come on go all the way back
what we're working on at Brookhaven
everything in the bottom
right corner of this is really designed
to bring data to two analysis routines
and a reliable reproducible metadataful
way that idea everybody's over expose
over HTTP authenticate HTTP to the world
and to try to solve that problem by just
putting all the data in one place
however uh this is a space that I know a
lot of people are very interested in I
don't know I've talked I've had
conversation Michelle about this
um this is a that's a very good question
and I don't think there is a super
there's a lot of answers and I don't
know which one is best yet
Academy
um can you tell us about the time that
you all that you've deleted like two
years
okay so uh this is I was an undergrad
and the last task
I had as I was leaving I was doing some
undergraduate research my last task of
leaving was to uh you know clean up you
know all the work I've done burn it to a
DVD because it was that long ago
and
you know editors like would create like
the temporary files where it's like file
name squiggle and I said oh I don't want
to back up those Forever on DVD so I
typed RM space star space squiggle enter
and deleted two years of Matlab
uh
had a panic you know basically on the
floor and tried to breathe for five
minutes
uh fortunately I had also been like
adding comments and like editing so I
happen to have every single file open in
a text editor
so I went through and like put a space
in and saved again so I ended up not
losing anything but like that was a
scarring experience and now everything
goes in Version Control immediately
yes
um
how does how do you kind of like in an
academic environment kind of like
navigate being able to also like get
some fellow researchers videos
so the question is an academic setting
unlike the business setting how do you
convince um you know pis and other
researchers that these things are
important
um
that that's also a hard question uh
the Communist had to use pis of anything
which is true there
uh yeah Michelle says money which is
not not admit not true yeah it's a
reasonable path
um
I think the best you can do is show
success if you do these you know over
the course of my graduate career at the
beginning you know my lab mates were
like nerd uh but by the end as I was
able to turn out cool stuff some of them
started like paying attention to what I
was doing and start adopting some of the
techniques themselves so I think you
know
do you know be successful and you know
that's for sure okay that's terrible
advice
uh
and you know if you find people who are
interested in listening work with them
instead of necessarily going at tilting
at windmills that are not interested in
moving right now
they said the Grassroots a little awful
I think that's that's the technique I
would take if you're
if you're higher up there's politics
that are above my head where you can
like go after money but uh
longer
to get them refilled because I had to be
doing this recently and they've got a
little more wiggled room than somebody
so the the comment from the crowd was
that postdocs are actually an extremely
good position to be the lover to change
the culture within academic departments
because they probably were recently in
the trenches doing it and have enough
wiggle room that and like you know
implying Authority that they can make
these changes and Advocate that for them
whereas the first year student probably
can't with that I think are we at time
[Applause]